ich bin zwar hier irgendwie gefunden
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge gemeinschaft war zusammen
mit tina fey
und wie geht's mir mir geht's gut ich
bin immer noch auf der suche nach dem
letzten diamanten den ich brauche mir
endlich mal schuhe zu machen ja
durchsucht später zog aber ja ich mache
mir gleich auf jeden fall so viel
bücherregalen und nicht die taktik geile
bücher ich hab auch 19 level dann kann
ich auch direkt irgend ein bisschen
jedoch eine schöne ecke das muss man
sagen dass wir was wir also ich muss
echt den ein jemanden ich bin auf der
suche nach dem letzten diamanten aber
wir wollen ja auch umziehen wieder in
dieser episode oder jetzt wo wir auch
gemerkt haben in der letzten folge dass
ihre cdu ich bin jetzt seit ihr
unterwegs um uns um schleicht okay da
suche ich schon eine neue base sondern
ziehe ich ziehe ich einfach bin ich in
dieser episode des umzugs komitee am
besten du hast sogar jetzt am anfang der
folge schon mal wieder keinen stress
weil ich mache ich mache ich damit wir
keinen stress haben alles alles lobt wie
sie mache ich mache ich würde wird
erledigt kein problem conny ich bin da
ich bin da bin ich voll deiner weise das
ist okay das ist zehnmal wiederholt beim
1 kommentar stil 1a freut mich immer
wenn ich höre ich finde einfach nix los
und wo sind die bands von denen das ist
mein gott ich glaube ich mit diesem
blumenschein gelandet wir sind ja nur
blumen
blumen die pilze
supergeil normal
wir sind nur blumen ich habe ich noch
nie gesehen so viele blumen auf einem
haufen das ist ja unglaublich alleine
umziehen wird mega lang dauern kann
ihnen bist du dir hoffentlich bewusst du
musst ja gar nicht mal so weit weg ja
aber alt ein bisschen ja damit bin ich
gleich wieder von von irgendwelchen tnt
fallen überrascht werden das wäre nicht
so lustig also ich habe mich das
wichtigste schon mal eingepackt da ziehe
ich jetzt einfach jetzt einfach um ja
ich ganz alleine nehme das gepäck auf
die schultern während während conny ist
uns was veranstaltet ich finde wenn man
zuckerrohr das ist das ist gut dass ich
hasse dich mal wirklich ich habe hier
schon 38 kollegin anna daraus können
erwartet wie viele bücher kann ich weiß
nicht auf jeden fall ein paar eier
[ __ ] sich gerade eben zwei schafe in
den arsch so ist will ich natürlich
indem man den mann zwar natürlich
nachschauen kann wenn uns irgendjemand
mal wieder auf den ferien wieder neue
folgen aufgenommen geht aus das stimmt
das stimmt wir sind sowieso komplett als
übrigens noch länger als eineinhalb
monate also bis pfingsten andauert
müssen wir auch mal was aufnehmen da
müssen wir uns dann am besten mehrere
börsen man ja ja ja ich bin halt monate
dauert im mai bin ich auch welt dass ich
bin schon früher weg aber nur für vier
tage das heißt da müssen wir dann auch
irgendwie gucken
inwiefern sich da was machen lässt oder
eben nicht die seien habe das projekt
hier dingen hier schon gewonnen
ja das ist ja eigentlich auch schon
gewonnen weil wir wissen haben wir alle
8000 mal im voraus auf die erste fackel
die konnte von dir kommen oder von
irgend jemand anders rapper ist weiß ich
weiß nicht ob ich so einen
offensichtlichen platz wählen soll für
unsere neue base was was sagst du dazu
was möchtest du denn das was wir überall
in der welt sind fallen von mir das
fallen weil fackeln von mir weil ich
nicht wollte dass nicht die zuschauer
beschweren dass irgendwie aber ich
glaube ich finde gleich die base das
sieht ja alles ein bisschen danach aus
ich mag ihn aus dem weg hier noch ein
bisschen mit fackeln und dann brauche
ich uns jetzt einfach mal hier ein das
ist eine sehr sehr offensichtlich spot
eigentlich aber ich möchte einfach mal
kurz sporadisch den umzug hinter mich
bringen und dann ist es okay da kann ich
auch wieder strip mal hingehen aber ich
habe ein bisschen ein bisschen mehr
platz für die ganze welt und erholen ich
würde ja gern mal irgendwie so von
seinen querschüssen von der mep ja oder
allgemein so eine so eine karte am ende
wo die verschiedenen basis waren mit
wohl jemand darauf so die diversen jahr
basis basis passen passen dann hast du
heute hat aber auch wirklich irgendwie
ein problem mit mir kann es sein können
auf jeden fall bis ins ewige tag ist
heute zeigt das noch mal bis zu ein
bisschen rektal auf die fresse kann das
sein dass ich find nix ich kann echt
heulen ich glaube die ganze zeit nur an
der wand her das ist ja mal so
langweilig ich fühle dass ich finde es
mega spannend
ich finde es total super was du warst du
machst allgemein also na ja wenigstens
ein bisschen zucker und eine ganzen
kanal für mich total genial areal den
kanal das beste channeling hier gesehen
habe nicht zu fassen oder krass einfach
dein ganzes leben
es sind ja mach doch einfach mal einfach
macht er schon wieder nacht ich bin zwar
hier irgendwie gefunden
echte ist dass starkes gefunden weil ich
jetzt hier machen ja kuckuck was du aus
aus den ungeschützten tun oder öffnen
hilft nichts wenn ich war einfach mal
alles ab hier ne also austria ist an
ideen gehört das darfst du genau du
darfst ist natürlich böse ja ganz klar
und man man man und im echten leben
würdest du das nie tun aber die regeln
die jedoch im echten würde ich auch zu
dir nach hause kommen einfach als du das
alles kaputtmachen was nicht was was
nicht protect ist mit mit einem schild
alles
wie stark die wohl ein bisschen weit
unten gefunden dafür bin ich auch nur um
die halbe welt gelaufen
ich passe auf dass ihr nicht irgendwie
ist das ist das von von regenzeit und
und debitor genau
ja die haben von dem opfer die dachten
natürlich auch mutwillig z das ist das
spiel
die werden auch absolut nicht sauer
bestimmung oder war er der firma lava
die frau die wohnen in einem strip mein
system echt ja das ist wahrscheinlich um
jetzt auch so menschen wie dich zu
verwirren
wenn da erst mal zauberte mitnehmen
gewachsen im verlaufe der drei- viermal
die beiden antworte mit
also ich habe jetzt ja wie viel zucker
aus zu ich hab 29 das reicht locker für
die ganze bücherregale wenn wir doch in
china haben die leder wenn man als kunde
ja durch nehmen alles mit hier einfach
alles mitgenommen
man darf sehr zerstören ach du und ich
habe mir sogar effizienz bücher aber das
ist nicht mal die projekte des das ist
die projekte da darf natürlich nicht
reingucken ganz tollen sachen drin sonst
ja die haben auch nicht sogar worden
jetzt aber ich umzug der riester lose
stieg ein umzug der ist schön ja das
übrigens wieder ein schild damit von
wegen die unproduktiven geld ja wie
waterboy gemacht haben bin ich toll
damit falle das ist ganz geil hier ist
eisen helm und brustpanzer mit schutz 1
aber das willst also dem ogv alle kaputt
zu machen
ja es wäre blöd aber ich darf also dass
daran die nämlich ewige folgen jetzt
daran gearbeitet aber es wäre natürlich
gut
du darfst du es ist natürlich projekt ja
ja bist du bist bei der mordfall von
denen ich bin gerade bei der mob falle
von denen ich ein bisschen xp hier
einfach ok holte erst mal ein bisschen
xp das böse weil ich habe einfach
also ich hoffe denen die folgen gar
nicht aber ich habe nur gesehen von
wegen das irgendwie in drei von den
letzten folge hat immer da stand bau der
amokfahrt falle fertig und sonst was
also das scheint das zu sein an dem die
lange gewerkelt zwar gewerkelt haben und
das natürlich schon heftig wenn du das
jetzt nicht zerstören ich weiß nicht wie
ich drauf bin
obschon ich überlasse das ich will dass
das deinen deinen hand bieten ja
zerstören oder zerstören nicht mal
einfach alles anzünden
es ist ein pvp projekt
natürlich ist er regelkonform also wir
hatten natürlich trotzdem den übelsten
hält platzieren für diese folge
ja aber gerade das sind ja diese witzige
sachen und ihr wolltet ihr mal so ein
bisschen so was ich habe jetzt zwei
folgen dieser schein space von den hier
gesucht er gut dann ist es auch so etwas
verdient aber nur weil es ja nicht böse
gemeint ist natürlich auch schon von der
seite mensch
daher stufen sind dem opfer das wäre es
noch du ja ja schaffen damit kein ding
natürlich kein aber ich war auf jeden
fall ins porno ab die als richtiges
browner will ich auf jeden fall
mitnehmen können sie wieder neuen
besorgen hier zu ende
ich kann nicht einsammeln kann man sich
einsam der hans baur schuldig
entschuldigung dass man konnte es jedoch
drei hektar kaputt ich glaub ich hab
halt alles wichtige was ich mitnehmen
will und sollte wenn ich gleich mal die
basis rein gucken ob da noch irgendwas
israelische spieler kaputt 28 level
haben sie starke baut hier für mich 28
level krass ist viel das ist ja ich
jetzt mal die ganzen kiste nähe von
denen ab 28 level ist ganz schön
hausnummer l coni dass ich da hast du
hast aber ganz schön was was krasses
abgezogen ja du die kiste von denen
steht ja noch habe ich nicht nein gesagt
wird verstoßen kein regelverstoß oder so
ist man heute wenn ihr daran dass die
folge heftig dagegen kannst du auch ich
halte auch dagegen spreche ich mal
wieder in die luft klima hier irgendwie
schilder oder so schildert es schildert
ende werden sich so aufregen weil sie
musste mal vorstellen ich baue drei
folgen lang an amokfahrer rum und dann
ist das einfach weg und nebendran ist so
ein schild danke für die mob falle die
unproduktiven mit seinem blöden auto im
alter jetzt ist aber mal wieder wenn sie
jetzt also ich bin aber ich freue mich
fall ist schon echt wieder es ist so so
ein so ein unverschämtes glück schon
wieder also nicht glück du hast erzählt
natürlich danach geguckt wo die fall ist
aber das war gerade gut die das ist ja
eine der effektivsten bases
logischerweise ja wenn ihnen abfall
haben das ja ist ja krass und so
deswegen ja
solche für die sachen lg die
unproduktiven dann gehe ich mal wieder
raus
guck mal was sie sonst noch so alles
wissen ja sonst nichts mehr was man
irgendwie abschreiben könnte also unsere
unser umzug ist auf fast fertig das habe
ich geschafft während der episode wie
komme ich denn jetzt da draußen das
alles jetzt möchte ich nur noch raus
retten erwarte da es hier muss ich
gleich lang ja genau hier muss lange ich
das dann so ein bisschen was in unserer
alten base aber da dass sie also
aussieht wie eine alte base ja das ist
ja ist ja okay dann könnte ich da leute
ein bisschen über dreck blöcke oder so
freuen das ist ja auch mal wieder super
was ist komme ich denn hier raus und
dann baut sich einfach nach oben oder so
darauf dass die join und schätze sie
allein weg mit deinem mac pippis krise
logistik für inserate hier ist dieser
raum
aber ich glaub ich hab ich dann haben
gesehen dass diese treppe davon da oder
ich weiß es gar nicht alltag entspannt
ich werde doch fünf minuten oder glaube
ich so etwas ja trotzdem sollten habe
ich angst
sie ist nur kabel stone drin das recht
sich nämlich mit das ist mir dass wir
dann schon zu viel des guten
schild aber das ganze kapital kann man
da drin ist als altem umziehen
jaja ich das so also kabellos und hätte
dass ich halt drin das braucht er kein
schwein dass ich heute einfach hier so
zackig welche schon wieder an der pace
von denen so da könnte ich jemand über
die badisch freuen
bitte schön und ich bin dann mal weg
freut euch über die biologie weiter
hinten ist dann also kannst du deinen
pfarrer braun gehen ja erledigt das
video news jetzt können was andere
schreiben kinos fast tot
conny findet basis war das wort das in
der episode mit dem titel was inter
lässt es nicht wir sind ja schon wieder
mal wieder auf dem allerneusten stand
was unsere episoden
aber das hat ja mittlerweile diamanten
gefunden dass sie voller
berührungspunkte ich bin umgezogen wie
soll ich dann trotzdem gern gesehen was
entdecken zu vermeiden drin ist aber ich
darf ja nicht reingucken das ist ja auch
ein regelverstoß you are not allowed to
look inside
aber da möchte ich jetzt auch mal loben
ich meine abseits davon dass jetzt
vielleicht debitor und reggae fans sich
ein wissen ja was ja einfach also man
kann es ja verstehen wenn du ein
bisschen unmut herrscht aber es ist ja
wie gesagt dafür regelkonform wichtig
und man hier von meiner seite aus betont
und ansonsten finde ich das aber cool
aus trier ist dass du die basis hat sich
gefunden hat das ist ja auch irgendwie
eine leistung
ja ich habe wirklich in deren folge nur
ein mal reingeguckt wie halte ich vom
intro hatten wie die irgendwie in ihre
basis rein klasse darf mit merck habe
ich mal gesehen ich bin jetzt halten nur
eine falsche richtung gelaufen war ein
bisschen doof welcher höre ich dann 42
bin ich aber sonst auch ein dickes lob
von mir an mich wirklich unglaublich gut
gemacht da ist jetzt auch mal also meine
mama ist auch die schon seit zwei
minuten hier am ausrasten das glaubst
gar nicht immer wieder unglaublich mit
schleppern diesmal von crafter drauf
statt mein name aber das ist mir auch
ein bisschen ja dass wenn das da
draufsteht ist doch nicht mehr normal
wie das läuft bei uns läuft einfach
wunderbar aber auch genügend zucchero
beide von unserem guten level das heißt
wir uns wieder nicht sehr wahrscheinlich
wieder fleißig an 36 zuckerrohr der
nächsten folge manager der firma zu dir
hin latschen
das wären dann
machen wir da einfach ein bisschen aber
dass der episode bau dich bitte ein
bevor du dich aus loks mache ich
original macht das macht das mal so
erwähnen dass von dieser episode wieder
aufreißt
ja natürlich natürlich aber einfach zur
zur zur sicherheit ist mir das lieber
wenn du eingebaut bist ja dann sieht man
dich auch nicht und das ist auch für den
rest entweder muss es ja nicht
übertreiben mit ja gut ich bin glücklich
hab ich zwar nicht eigentlich bringt das
übrigens damit unsere doppel bay sands
scheiß was weil inzwischen kennt ja
jeder die taktik von uns vermute ich mal
solche doppel base trotzdem noch weiter
machen welche doppel base also weiter so
vorne einen vorraum und 1 2 hinten dran
ja wenn ich drehe sagen muss ich das
unbedingt belgrad war bei biete wie viel
minuten habe er dennoch ich hoffe dass
14 minuten 50 führt zwar das recht das
recht für kaum noch was
das riecht für gomez kommt plötzlich hat
man schnell um hier manchmal das halt
mal das teilt ihm halt noch mal
einrahmen weiter einräumen weiter das
war mal wieder gut gerutscht
ja ich laufe jetzt einfach irgendwie
eine mitte und von der mitte weiß ja
dann wo wir dann in etwa hingelaufen
sind klar ich ja ja ja ich glaub ich
möchte das noch hinkriegen
ein kombi coupé und kombi kombi schmich
besucher komme aber leider wollte nicht
lange drin bleiben die ganze zeit
gedanken darüber was von meinen
kommentaren steht so von die ganze
bandbreite von [ __ ] sonderbar vollidiot
aber fick deine mutter
das steht ja immer drin ja also nichts
neues eigentlich das ist ja auf youtube
video das jetzt so guten standards mich
doch werden sie auch ausgiebig erklärt
dass das halt regelkonform ist und das
ist ein paradies auf erden werden die
meisten hoffentlich inzwischen irgendwie
verstanden haben und ansonsten kann man
ja auch nicht mehr viel helfen
mein patrick wurde auch dafür erhält das
erste mal habe ich habe ich auch schon
angesprochen
verständlich also haltet petric folge
gelegt um dagegenzuhalten sowieso alle
dass du einer bist du einer der folgen
neigt ja das ist krass freilich wird
sagen dass mit der episode verletzt
nicht dass du alles hier zu bewerten
wenn es euch gefallen hat und den defekt
dagegenhalten
natürlich sagen